a closing campaign in the province of
buenos aires a coalition government
trying to set their differences aside in
spite of the enormous contradictions
that exist between president alberto
fernandez and his powerful vice
president christina fernandez kirchner
the first condition that we need to
concentrate on because the opposition is
trying to prevent it is the unity of our
country that is the unity of the immense
majority of the argentine people
fernandez and kirschner came to power
almost two years ago in what was widely
regarded as a marriage of convenience
despite being a popular former president
of argentina she says she knew she did
not have enough votes to win the 2019
election on her own and needed a
candidate who could support her
continued aspirations for high office
but almost two years after the pandemic
began the coalition is struggling as
demonstrated by its defeat last
september in the primary elections
there's a big question in argentina
right now and that is who is running the
country is the president alberto
fernandez or the powerful vice president
christina fernandez the kirchner whose
confrontational style with the business
sector has won her thousands of
supporters many of them are present here
today even though they both belong to
the peyronie's party the differences
between them bring uncertainty to the
ruling coalition
but at this pro-government rally
supporters say there is not a crisis
mario chamorro says this agreement is
welcome in the ruling coalition
dissent is good within one political
space in a coalition there should be
differences or it would be a monolithic
movement there is dissent in a marriage
so imagine in a political movement
argentines will head to the polls to
renew half of congress and a third of
the senate
the question is whether the paronys
party will be able to turn around its
massive defeat during the primary
elections in september and what will
happen if it can't
analysts say the election will define
the balance of power in government
what's going to be clear after the
election is that if christina moves
around 30 of the votes that alberta
cannot add an extra vote and others
cannot either it's easy to understand
that christina is going to eat them
alive or has the capacity to do it
you're going to have a president with no
power and we're going to see how that
ends
political uncertainty can only intensify
economic instability in argentina as the
country struggles to recover from the
pandemic and pay billions in foreign
debt
with millions of argentines stuck in the
middle teresa al jazeera buenos aires